(cell phone rings)
(Ahamed groans)
- [Ahamed Voiceover] My
name is Ahamed Weinberg.
This year, like many before
it, I'm fasting for Ramadan.
That means I wake up
before the sun rises,
and eat everything in my fridge,
and then I can't eat
again until the sun sets.
I do this for an entire month.
(kettle whistles)
But you're probably wondering
why is your last name Jewish?
Why are you white?
What is happening?
Let me explain.
My mother was one of 10 children
in an Irish-Catholic family.
One day, she joined a
Native American tribe,
and they called her Hat Woman.
Better than Sunblock, I guess.
This is her at the end
of her spiritual journey
as a Sufi Muslim.
She was never sunburnt again.
In 1988, she married a
Jewish man from Brooklyn
who had also found Islam.
Look at that nose.
The answering machine in
my house growing up was
"As-salamu alaykum. You've
reached the Weinbergs.
"Please leave a message."
Nobody left a message.
I go crazy every day.
I can't drink or eat.
I usually want to have sex
with my fridge around four.
She's old and her
skin is yellow.
She doesn't stop humming but...
Something about her I love.
It's what's inside that counts.
[refrigerator humming]